I read an article
yesterday Tony sne snail
yeah I needing to be signed by the end
of this week cuz he's got two kids with
autism and he needs to play to the end
of the year to get a
10year medical right to help him take
care of his two autistic kids I'm hoping
you know man the NBA's been great to all
of us sitting up here uh you know and
you guys going to be playing basketball
forever making gazillion dollars I hope
one of you guys signed Tony so his two
autistic kids can get great medical care
I read that article or is the league
just or Adam Silva comes in and it makes
an deception and he gets the gets the I
mean it's it's only it's only 40 games
so he can make well I'm just telling you
he EAS well no I'm just saying I I hope
a team signs him for the rest of the
season because you know I don't know a
lot about autism I a going to say it but
man I know it's got to be expensive to
have two young kids with that situation
so I'm hoping the NBA we always talk
about what a family we are right let's
let's sign that kid for the rest of the
season